[Musique]
la montre c'est le seul
objet manufacturé qui a une
signification profonde par rapport à la
vie parce qu'il mesure notre il garde
notre
temps
une montre c'est un objet qui permet de
lire l'heure accessoirement et qui est
devenu quelque chose de
complètement je dirais anachronique dans
ce monde puisque si on veut avoir
l'heure avec l'électronique on l'
parfaitement et c'est plus un un un
bijou en mouvement et maintenant on me
propose même de faire des montres qui
n'ont plus d'aiguille justement pour
aller jusqu'au paroxisme de de cet état
l'objet est vraiment
inutile étrange parole de la bouche d'un
homme dont le métier est de fabriquer
cet objet à y regarder de près il n'a
pourtant probablement pas
tort
à quoi bon s'encombrer le poignet d'une
montre nous sommes cernés par une
batterie d'objets dont la raison de
vivre est de nous aider à vivre et qui
tous nous donne
l'heure alors pourquoi porter une
montre c'est une petite ironie de
l'histoire un retour aux origines quand
la montre apparu au 16e siècle elle
était si fantasque qu'elle donnait
l'heure à quelques heures près si bien
qu'une seule aiguille
suffisait la montre n'était autre qu'une
horloge miniature portable que les gens
de la haute société affiché comme un
[Musique]
bijou le public deapparition de la
montre c'est un public priner
essentiellement ou de grand bourgeois
car la montre à l'époque est un objet de
prestige essentiellement puisque la
montre par elle-même ne règle pas elle
règle à quelques heures par jour elle
est pratiquement inutilisable la montre
à ses début est simplement ovale
relativement rustique elle se portait à
l'époque attaché autour du cou par la
suite elle s'est progressivement
miniaturisé elles ont été faites de plus
en plus compliqué soit plus petite soit
avec des indications
astronomiques avant de capturer le temps
dans une petite boîte les hommes
inventèrent l'orloge cette montre
publique fixe imposante trôné au cœur
des villages dès la fin du 14e siècle
son mécanisme était capricieux et ses
rouages demand des attentions
permanentes à cette époque là quand on
achetait qu'on faisait installer une
horloge de de tour de bfroid et cetera
il fallait engager l'horlog en même
temps il fallait un spécialiste il y
avait tant de
problèm
[Musique]
on ne sait pas qui a inventé la montre
on ne sait même pas où ça a été inventé
on sait à peu près quand les premières
montres paraissaient au début du 16e
siècle et on sait enfin qui étai les
grands inventeur de vie qui ont amélioré
cet
[Musique]
instrument
on n pas encore au 16e siècle des
montres qui seraient qui donneraient la
même heure que la montre d'autrui mais
même pour organiser son propre temps
c'était un grand avantage dans une armée
par exemple s'il y avait l'heure donnée
par la montre du général cette heure
servait parce que tout le monde suivait
le signal même si la montre était 1
heure en avance sur le soleil ou une
heure en arrière
ce signal était le signal qui comptait
c'est pour ça qu'on trouve souvent que
des princes et des généraux voulait
avoir tes montres même deses montres
inexactes nous avons tous fait ce geste
ne serait-ce qu'une fois à chaque fois
nous redonnons vie à notre montre nous
remontons son
ressort et si les montres aujourd'hui
savent donner l'heure avec précision ell
le doivent à cette minuscule lamelle
métallique enroulée comme une coquille
d'escarb
sous notre il chirurgical un mécanisme
de montre dans son plus simple appareil
organe vital le barer le ressort est
bien à l'abri à
l'intérieur pour démultiplier la force
du ressort le train de
rouage puis les pièces de l'organe
réglant la roue d'échappement avec sa
denture
spécifique et le
balancier
à l'origine les ressorts de montrre
n'étaient autre que des lames de métal
forgé aujourd'hui c'est un élément d'une
très grande précision dans la
montre les matériaux utilisés à partir
de la fin du 19e siècle pendant une
bonne partie du 20e siècle étent des
aciers au carbone ou à texture
inox et
actuellement on utilise un alliage
spécial au
COB le ressort a toujours été àire de
spécialiste quand on ouvre une montre
ancienne il arrive souvent de trouver
son ressort signé par le fabricant de
l'époque aujourd'hui la machine a
remplacé le
métallurgiste la machine Lamine le fil
d'acier pour faire un la puis le découpe
à la bonne
longueur
elle lui donne sa forme de Coquillon et
pour finir le roule en
spirale une dernière cuisson à plus de
400 de et l'objet est fin
prais prêt à faire battre le cœur d'une
montre
la grande révolution technique de la
montre arrive au 17e siècle dans le
derniers quart du siècle c'était surtout
l'invention du spirale et ce n'est
qu'avec l'invention du spiral qu'on a en
contrôleur qui a en quelque sorte
régulariser n'est-ce pas la marche du
mouvement la première conséquence de
l'invention du spiral réglant par hgin a
été de produire des montres à deux
aiguilles la deuxième aiguille
l'aiguille des minutes étant inutile
auparavant contenue de l'inexactitude de
ses montres la deuxème conséquence il a
fallu loger le spiral réglant c'estd le
ressort du balancier et il a fait lu
produire des montres avec un balancier
plus grand d'où la conséquence de ces
montres très épaisses qui en raison de
la forme de leur forme ont été baptisés
auion ce qu'on voit avec l'invention du
spirale par aens en
1675 c'était surtout la diffusion de la
montre comme instrument normal de la vie
commerciale de la vie euh d'affaires de
la vie professionnelle à un taux qui
aurait été inconcevable avant parce que
L ilité de la montre a été énormément
rehaussée par cette nouvelle
exactitude des données de
l'heure alors la vraie recherche c'est
d'arriver à faire une monondte qui
fonctionne aujourd'hui sans SPIR celui
qui arrivera aura fait une très grande
invention mais je dis que c'est un axe
de recherche je dis pas que c'est
faisable ce qu'il y a de beau quand on
regarde une montre avec une loupe on
voit les engrenages les petites pièces
qu'on discerne pas avec les yeux
lorsqu'on les regarde de façon naturelle
on
rentre dans les pignons dans les dents
on s'aperçoit que une petite poussière
parfois pourrait venir bloquer le rouage
que c'est un débrri pour être un pieux
comp relativement à une montre une
automobile même de très bonnes marques
vous feriez marcher sans arrêt de la
même façon ça dura une vie de 3 mois et
dans une monte c'est 10 ans et on la
nettoie ça repart c'est
[Musique]
extraordinaire le 18e siècle est le
siècle des Lumières et de l'horlogerie
le jur à Suisse va devenir peu à peu le
pays de la montre et pour des raisons
bien terre à terre les paysans juraciens
vivent de l'élevage et de la forêt les
hivers sont rudes et la neige cantonne
les hommes à des travaux d'entretien à
la ferme habile pour toutes sortes de
petits travaux et inactifs durant les
longs mois d'hiver les paysans
comprennent vite que la fabrication de
montres leur sera
profitable peu à peu les montagnares
abandonnent S et Charu pour l'artisanat
horlogé parmi eux géant Jacques blampin
qui ouvre son atelier horlogé en 1735
créant ainsi la première marque de
montre du
[Musique]
monde aujourd'hui un des fleurons de la
marque est le calibre 1735 hommage à
l'histoire de la
[Musique]
marque
au milieu du 18e les montres se sont
simplement un peu miniaturisées tout en
conservant la même forme mais elles ont
été produites en or très souvent émaillé
elles étaient alors
portées à la ceinture accroché à une
châelaine grand maître dans l'histoire
de la montre est suisse par la naissance
mais c'est à Paris qu'Abraham Louis
breget donnera toute la mesure de son
art il y fonde sa maison en 1775 sous le
règne de Louis XV monarque lui aussi
horlogé qui connaîtra la fin tragique
que l'on
sait il a choisi de faire les montres
les plus
impressionnante par leur beauté par leur
simplicité par leur élégance
les montres breget ont donné le standard
à toutes les autres montres
depuis parler des apports de bregay
c'est un très vaste sujet parce que
breget
a disons a fait évoluer toutes les
branches de l'horlogerie et toutes les
facettes de la montre depuis le
mouvement et tous ces composants jusqu'à
la boîte jusqu'au cadran jusqu'au décor
on peut dire en gros que breget a appuré
breget toute sa vie a simplifié tant sur
le plan mécanique que sur le plan
esthétique c'est quelqu'un qui appure
qui enlève tout ce qui est inutile et
qui crée un style extrêmement sobre qui
est celui de la montre
moderne dans la myiade de brevet et
invention signé bregé le tourbillon de
1801 restera
célèbre toujours en service sur
certaines montre modern le tourbillon
compense les dérèglements de la montre
dû à ses changements de position dans
l'espace attaché au poignet de son
propriétaire beaarché est un autre grand
maître moins connu c'est vrai pour son
art horlogé que pour son Barbier ou son
Figaro et
pourtant bon marché le grand
dramaturge
et écrivain était d'abord un horlogier
il était un horlogier plus que compétent
son nom de famille c'était Caron et les
Caron c'était une dynastie dans le je et
et surtout après s'être montré comme un
homme de grande originalité de talent
littéraire ça causait pas mal euh
d'embêtement de jalousie parmi des gens
qui le trouvait un homme prétentieux
n'est-ce pas et qui devait être mise à
sa place alors un jour il y a un type
qui arrive et il dit Monsieur Caron hein
c'est pas un accident il n'a pas dit bon
marché monsieur Caron on me dit que vous
êtes très bon horlogé j'ai ma montre ici
qui ne marche pas très bien est-ce que
vous pourriez jeter un coup d'œil et
peut-être faire quelque chose pour moi
alors il était offusqué bon marcha et il
savait très bien que cet homme
l'insultait et alors il a pris la montre
il a laissé tomber sur le marbre et
alors évidemment ça s'est cassé le type
était consterné et furieux mais bon
marché dit mais vous voyez monsieur que
je ne suis plus aussi fort en orlogerie
[Musique]
qu'autrefis à la date du 30 décembre 18
130 on trouve une montre vendue au
compte de
l'épine avec une grande innovation le
premier remontoir sans clé le premier
bouton moleté qui remplace la clé pour
leur
montage pour remonter la montre il
suffit de faire tourner entre l'index et
le pouce de droite à gauche le bouton
d'or moleté qui est dans le pendant on
continue de rouler ce bouton entre les
doigts jusqu'à ce que l'on sente l'arrêt
c'est la première mention d'un remontoir
sans clé dans l'histoire de l'horlogerie
contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser le prix d'une montre est
absolument indépendant de son ancienneté
une montre très ancienne comme par
exemple celle-ci qui date en gros de
1600 ne vaut que quelques milliers de
Fran de francs suisses parce qu'elle
n'est pas en parfait état ou qu'elle a
subi des restauration par contre une
montre très moderne comme le calibre 89
de Patek Philippe qui a été terminé
comme son nom l'indique en
1989 a été vendu pour plus de 5 millions
de francs
suisses
ce paire de montre elle va maintenant
être contrôlé par les orlogers qui vont
la préparer pour pour la
photo notre idée est qu'elle de de
sauver d'un côté la mémoire et de faire
connaître plus de mond possible euh
qu'est-ce que a été fait donc pas
seulement pour la montre BL salé dans ce
dernier siècle siècle Mo aussi qu'est-ce
qui a été fait 16e jusqu'aujourd'hui
c'est très important la montre c'est une
objet d'art ce n'est pas seulement une
un instrument et cet objet d'art à la
même il doit être traité à la même façon
qu' un tableau que qu'un
sculpture qui en B mble il y a la
capacité humaine des réalisation d'un
côté et il y a euh la technologie c'est
très important très important parce que
aujourd'hui toute notre civilisation il
se base sur la technologie et la montre
c'est le meilleur exemple de
ça les marques qui sont plus la côte
aujourd'hui sont évidemment la patrique
Philippe c'est la reine de la montre
vous avez Rolex au dear Pigué Vacheron
Constantin bregé quartier ils ont fait
des choses merveilleuses et c'est sur
leur passé et sur leur réalisation
d'aujourd'hui qui se base l'intérêt des
collectionneurs quelqu'un c-il l'en chè
de 4500 j' juge à 4500 sans regret à
4500 le numéro 6 g Le cultre réso
débutons à 30000 francs il y a preneur à
30000 300 francs nous sommes 31000 32
3000 32000 33000 35000 contre vous 36000
38000 40000 42000 45000 46000 47000
47000 à ma gauche quelqu'un com- l'enchè
de 47000 j' juge à 47000 sans regret à
47000 je vais à juger adjugé expert pour
acheteur
37 22000 francs quelqu'un c-il l'enchère
de 22500 23000 23500 24000 24000 25000
au téléphone 25000
2000lectionour de la marer l'tique mais
toujours en lieu le mécanisme et
puisamour de la montre
ême mécanisme mon lue plaisir avec un
beau bracelet B allure qui soit
quiment toutes les grandes marques
horlogeères ont fait des montres
prestigieuses inaccessibles pour des des
à mon niveau et et beaucoup de ces
montres font rêver c'est aussi ce qui
nous aide à perfectionner une collection
en essayant toujours d'aller vers le
haut ça fait plusieurs mois que je l'ai
j'ai du mal à la vendre donc c'est pas
parce que c'est pas une question de prix
c'est une question de d'attachement vous
voyez comme quoi un marchand peut être
collectionneur aussi je la porte depuis
le mois de décembre je porte très
souvent deux montres là quelque chose
qui est complètement complètement
différent qui ressemble le volant d'une
d'uneune voiture citroëne sera quelque
chose des années des années 50 c'était
une montre probablement publicitaire ou
qui était offerte avec une voiture à
l'époque mais bon c'est rigolo bon al
c'est complètement c'est atypique les
deux ça rien à voir absolument rien à
voir ni au niveau ni au niveau mécanisme
ni au niveau marque ni au niveau prix
j'étais collectionneur et au fur et à
mesure de que ma collection grandissait
je me suis mis dans le commerce de la
montre et aujourd'hui j'ai ouvert une
boutique le grand départ au milieu du
19e siècle c'est le départ vers
l'industrialisation la fabrication en
série les économistes qui essaie de
comprendre pourquoi on commence à
industrialiser la production de la
montre aurait euh la difficulté à
choisir entre la croissance de la
demande et les nouvelles possibilités
d'offre un nouveau venu se lance dans le
sport à saint-tinier dans le creusé de
l'horlogerie encore et toujours le jur à
Suisse le maître horloger darder fonde
sa maison en 1860 avec pour ambition
fabriquer des instruments précis et
solides en 1916 Heer fabrique le premier
chronographe au cè de
secondeer sera le chronomètreur officiel
olympiqu des années
20 ces
montresl sont sont maintenant non
seulement
l'apanage des hommes de substance et de
moyens mais
même des ouvriers et même des enfants
d'ouvriers on commence à donner des
montres comme
[Musique]
cadeaux
il n'y a pas d'obligation d'acheter une
montre il y a suffisamment d'objets qui
donnent l'heure et de monde peu cher ce
n'est pas un objet indispensable à la
vie comme des biens courant de première
nécessité comme la nourriture le
vêtement ou le logement c'est un luxe à
partir de ce moment-là la valeur qu'on y
met est totalement
subjective R
sec voilà donc je vais vous montrer
l'une des première montre de la
collection Versace horlogerie acier et
cuir ou alors or et cuire ça c'est un
mouvement automatique mouvement
mouvement automatique
d'accord
vous avez un miroir ou je pense que
elle aimera plus ce
modèle telle qui vous a parlé de cette
oui oui il a des amis qui l'ont vu aussi
qui lu ont dit il faut voir cette montre
la montre reste un métier d'horloger
vousz choix elle devient peut-être un
peu trop un objet de marketing mais elle
restera toujours un un domaine de
passionné des hommes et des femmes qui
sont passionnés par l'objet et qui à
leur niveau avec leurs compétences
concours à l'acte de construire et de
créer l'histoire retiendra que
l'invention de la montre bracelet est
une trouvaille
d'aviateur Santos Dumont en ce début de
siècle veut une montre qui puisse lui
donner l'heure de rapide coup d'œil sans
lâcher les commandes de son
Aéroplan il sollicite la maison quartier
qui s'exécute la Santos première montre
bracelet voit le jour en
1904 depuis elle s'est misise à la page
et se porte
encore une autre quartier fera tourner
la tête d'une star rudolp Valentino
tourne le fils du chèque la star exige
par contrat de garder sa montre au
poignet pendant le tournage aujourd'hui
encore l'anachronisme fait
[Musique]
sourire mais le vrai décollage de la
montre bracelet viendra des
militaires les premiers exemples qui
nous sont connus ont été des montrre qui
a été adapté des montres de poche de
gousset qui ont été adopté à la fond
brcelet par des soldats par des
officiers qui voulaient avoir quelque
chose qui pouvait attacher en dehors de
leurs manches alors ils ont pris des
montres de poche pour attacher un
bracelet l'évolution de la montre
bracelet doit être marquée certainement
tout de suite après la Première Guerre
mondiale quand les montres de poche
avaient été
transformées très sommairement en montre
bracelet mais ici c'est un exemple
classique d'une montre de dame pentatif
qui se se prêtait très facilement du
point de V grandeur à une montre
bracelet qui était à l'époque dans une
une un boîtier différent on voit que le
remontoir à l'origine était à MIDH on
tourne la pièce et elle est à sa place
normale à 3h et c'est elle était
incorporée cette pièce dans une une
montre bracelet classique avec des
attaches pour le bracelet
cuir en 1926 une montre réalise un
exploit au bras de la nageuse Mercedes
Glaz la oyster Rolex traverse la Manche
la oyster fermée comme une hîre résiste
à l'eau la première montre étanche vient
de
naître il est vrai qu'au point de vue
d'exactitude et de marche que la montre
de poche rester supérieur pendant un
certain temps ceci dit je dois dire que
la montre brcely était assez bonne pour
faire tout ce que la vie sociale et
culturelle voulait et demandait n'est-ce
pas il faut noter qu'il y a une tendance
pour les porteurs de montres d'avoir des
d'atteindre des niveaux de précision qui
dépassent leurs
besoins
nous créons à peu près une dizaine de
nouvelles boîtes par année et dans ce
processus de création évidemment
beaucoup de personnes interviennent donc
il y a les ingénieurs qui font la
recherche sur le le mouvement après il y
a les mécaniciens et toutes les gens
spécialisés dans la fabrication des des
composants donc ils doivent faire des
plans ils doivent faire passer ses plans
sur les machines qui vont découper les
pièces après les horlogers vont rentrer
en ligne de compte où ils vont faire des
essais sur les prototypes voir si le
mouvement tourne bien s'il y a des
modifications à faire donc il y a
beaucoup de métiers différents qui
interviennent dans la fabrication d'une
montre le secteur recherche et
développement est en amont de la chaîne
de production les concepteurs modélisent
les futures montres à coup
d'ordinateur dans les années 20 si les
techniques étaient plus rustiques le
principe était déjà le même
quand le modèle est prêt les machines à
commande numérique reproduisent les
différentes
[Musique]
pièces comme l'on construit une maison
on commence par les fondations la
platine PL sur laquelle viendront se
fixer les différentes pièces du
[Musique]
mouvement
moins rapide moins précise moins
complexe les machines d'autrefois usiné
pourtant selon les mêmes
[Musique]
règles la monte spécialement en Suisse
représente énormément dans histoire de
l'industrie suisse puisque c'est une
industrie qui est très forte c'est même
la troisè industrie de la Suisse et
disons qu'il y a eu beaucoup de
personnes qui ont travaillé pour pour la
fabrication d'une montre et donc tout
toutes les tous les Suisses disons sont
concernés par l'aspect technique et
l'aspect aussi de la beauté de d'une
pièce mais pas seulement les Suisses
beaucoup d'autres sont fiers de leur
chronographe à qutiè perpétuell et
répétitions minutes par exemple
autrement dit de leur montre donnant la
date en tenant compte des mois en 30 ou
31 jours et des années bisextiles
traduction du quantième perpétuel et
sonnant à volonté heure quart d'heure ou
minute traduction de la répétition
minute petite fierté également de porter
la montre adopté par les aviateurs la
naytimer de bitling qui fait référence
depuis
1954 rien d'étonnant à ce que la marque
entretienne cette référence pour vendre
ses montres même à ceux qui n'ont Jama
vu d'AV chasse
[Musique]
de Omega a choisi de percer la
stratosphère et de s'associer aux
aventuriers de
l'espace en 1964 la Speedmaster résiste
au tests particulièrement éprouvant que
lui infligent les techniciens de la
Nasan et devient la montre officielle
des
astronautes depuis la marque multiplie
les opérations de marketing pour
rappeler au public cette association
[Musique]
prestigieuse d'autres ont jeté leur
dévolu sur une star et en fond leur
ambassadeur Gary
Kasparov avait acheté un une Royal haw à
Paris quelques années avant que nous
soyons en relation d'affaires si je peux
dire et cette montre a toute une
histoire parce qu'il la met chaque fois
qu'il a une rencontre très importante à
son poignet mais lorsqu'il est à la
table de d'échec il pose la monte sur la
table en principe quand il reprend la
montre la remet à son poignet ça
signifie qu'il estime que la partie est
gagnée et c'est toujours un certain
nombre de coup avant la fin de la partie
alors l'histoire raconte que la première
fois qu'il a joué contre l'ordinateur
d'IBM il a mis la montre au poignet mais
l'ordinateur n'a pas compris il a dû
aller jusqu'à la fin de la
partie
tous ces efforts pour que personne
n'oublie qu'une montre est un instrument
de haute
[Musique]
précision notre métier est une réunion à
la fois de tradition et d'innovation il
faut avoir les technologies actuelles
les plus affutées les plus pointu les
meilleurs pour faciliter le travail pour
trouver des solutions rapides économique
et et et de grande qualité pour réaliser
des produits qui restent ancien dans
leur idée avec des moyens
actuels
[Musique]
dans la montre aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
eu d'invention fondamentale je dirais
depuis le 19e siècle la dernière c'est
Charles éedouard Guillaume qui a inventé
l'invar et les linvares qui sont des
matériaux euh fer nickel qui permettent
de de ne de ne pas se dilater aux
différentes températures mais
fondamentalement une roue une roue un
engrenage un engrenage un pignon un
pignon il y a pas beaucoup de différence
entre le 18e
aujourd'hui
voil c'est toujours étonnant de voir une
monte qui démarre travaille dessus
pendant longtemps voit toutes les pièces
qui se qui s'assemble les unes aux
autres et puis à un moment ça marche et
puis comme on est toujours dedans avec
une loupe on a jamais la vue vraiment
d'ensemble et quand on on a le recul
comme ça on se demande si c'est pas
quelqu'un d'autre qui l'a faite parce
que c'est très rare qu'on la regarde de
loin fonctionner on a toujours vu des
des petitte parties alors on peut rester
des heures à contempler c'est pas mal
critique heureux et
cetera un jour de Noël dans les années
60 je me trouvais dans ma dans ma salle
de bain avec une savonnette qui était
absolument usée j'ai avec mon ongle
tracé une ouverture de montre j'ai placé
mon
cuir et je me suis dit ça c'est vraiment
extraordinaire parce que c'est une ligne
qui n'a jamais été créée dans une
horloge dans une montre de poignet et
qui est tellement extraordinaire parce
que une savonnette c'est comme ça
je suis sorti de ma baignoire je l'ai
dessiné elle l'a donné naissance à la
ligne douce c'est
quelquefois de l'observation que
naissent les choses les plus simples et
les plus pures je n'ai rien inventé
c'était une savonette c'est devenu une
[Musique]
[Rires]
montre
[Musique]
si on veut avoir juste l'heure à son
poignet une belle une bonne montre à
quelques centaines de francs fait tout à
fait l'affaire mais quand on veut une
montre de luxe on porte un objet un
objet d'art on se fait plaisir on a
l'impression de porter sur le poignet
des Seces de tradition
[Musique]
rlogère ah c'est un c'est un rapport un
peu spécial que souvent les clients
n'imagin pas c'est que les clients
possèdent la montre mais nous nous la
possédons plus que parce que nous la
connaissons beaucoup mieux il faut
peut-être être un petit peu fou pour
faire ce ce métier du reste Jul Vern
écrit un de ces romans qui se passe sur
les ponts de Genève et qui parle d'un
horloger fou je me rappelle
malheureusement plus le
titre donc sur le timbre grave sonne les
heures
les quart
d'heur et les minutes sonnent sur le
timbre
[Musique]
aigu voyons ça maître Zacharius que se
passe-t-il donc dans cette bonne ville
de Genève on dit que votre santé
s'altère que vos montres ont besoin de
médecin vous croyez vous qu'il y a un
rapport intime entre leur existence et
la mienne moi j'imagine que ces montres
ont des défaut des VI même si ces
gaillardes là n'ont pas une conduite
fort régulière il est juste qu'elles
portent la peine de leur dérèglement il
met avis qu'elles auraient besoin de se
ranger un peu quand on déclenche la
répétition minute et que et que tout
d'un coup vous avez 4 C pièces qui qui
tombent sur des sur des cames et et puis
vous avez remonte vous avez des levées
qui qui sonnent qui qui qui font
actionner des marteaux ça c'est ça c'est
magique
la difficulté dans les pièces à sonnerie
c'est d'arriver à avoir le meilleur son
possible alors pour les pièces de poche
comme ceci c'est relativement facile
puisque les pièces sont d'une très
grande d'un grand diamètre et les les
boîtes sont sont en or et sont très
volumineuses donc ça donne un bon écho
mais pour les monondes bracelet c'est
déjà plus difficile et encore le choix
des matériaux rentre en ligne de compte
c'est-à-dire que les boîtes en platine a
tendance à moins bien sonner que les
pièces en or jaune les pièces
compliquées ne marchent jamais du
premier coup et et même du 2è ou du 3è
il y a c'est très souvent des des des
fonctions qu'il faut refaire plusieurs
fois pour arriver vraiment au au top
mais à un moment donné il faut s'arrêter
il faut se dire que euh la fonction est
bonne et ça va fonctionner autrement on
on peut tout casser et
recommencer cette montre c'est une c'est
une montre qui va rester 2 ans dans nos
ateliers la montre est quand même un
symbole aujourd'hui surtout la montre
mécanique donc la montre de luxe situe
disons que la valeur de de la personne
c'est également un bijou que l'homme
peut porter par exemple c'est le seul
bijou presque aujourd'hui qu'un homme
porte donc c'est une montre et disons
que effectivement comme les Américains
disent c'est un sorte de status
symbol
pour réaliser une
montre très chère très exceptionnelle en
prix il faut apporter une somme d'amour
et de sensibilité et de technologie et
de et de de novation je sais pas si le
mot est juste mais il faut
vraiment penser créer un chef-dœuvre
quand votre montre n'est plus une montre
et qu'il devient un chef-dœuvre elle n'a
plus de prix vous vous changez changez
de quelle
[Musique]
tonne vous vous changez changez de quel
tonne vous vous changer changer de quel
tonne à la fin des années 60 une
nouvelle venue boulve l'ordre établi
dans l'industrie horlogiaère classique
la montre à
quartz quartz a été inventé à la fin fin
des années euh
1920 je ve dire 28 par là euh ça apparu
d'abord dans des horloge ce n'est qu'à
la fin des années 60 qu'on est arrivé à
fabriquer des euh système de quartz
assez petit pour servir dans une montre
ce qui fait qu'à partir des années
1970 le quartz commence à prendre
plus une part de plus en plus grande du
marché horloger ça quelque
sorte renversé la l'industrie orlogère
suisse mon dit Christian il est 7h mais
non il est 6h encore ta
[Musique]
montre au 3e TIC il sera exactement 7h
j'ai quelque chose pour toi
Timex électrique pas de ressort une pile
en
1974 le problème était grave en Suisse
parce que Logerie japonaise Hong Kong
Japon et surtout Logerie électronique
est en train de détruire Logerie
mécanique donc après avoir mise en
valeur le l' Rogerie ancienne la belle
pendolerie nous avons essayé de faire
comprendre l'importance de la montre
brcalé dans la dans l'histoire de l'
Rogerie enfin la montre brassalé n'est
que la petite fille de la de la montre
de poche
et un petit peu la fois nous sommes
arrivés à créer une vra passion cette
passion c'est s'est développée à niveau
mondial et je crois que grâce aux
maisons des ventes aux enchers l'orerie
Suisse en généralerie
mécanique 1000 au fond personne de 13000
au téléphone en voulez-vous il existe
des montres à quartz qui affichent en
permanence l'heure et les minutes
on appuie seulement pour le mois et le
jour puis les
secondes et bien cette montre précise au
43 m Dee a été cré en
1977 et elle fonctionne comme au premier
jour
10h10 mais vous avez une jolie
montre et ça marche comment avec une
pileve ou comme ça c'est deterilà vous
êtes content
oui mais alors si on n pas besoin de la
remonter à quoi ça sert le remontoir à
faire parler les
bardard pour l'horlogerie traditionnelle
le choc est brutal et cette nouvelle
concurrente va faire des ravages cette
montre à la mode est bien moins ch et
pour Couron tout bien plus préc
l'industrie de la montre mécanique
accuse le PER per pourer les assuts de
la montre à quz principalement les
fabricants réagissent en produisant
moins l'échec la montre mécanique
devient un objet de luxe en Suisse une
industrie horlogère vitale pour le pays
un groupe d'hom choisit notre vie ils
ont l'idé de combattre le mal par le mal
pour par
le la Swatch a été inventée aux années
80 c'était en quelque sorte une réponse
au
défi de la montre à quartz et c'est le
produit c'est l'invention de gens qui
n'était pas horlogé de naissance ou
d'État mais plutôt spécialiste des
composants électroniques alors ils ont
réussi formidablement mais ils ont
changé de personnalité en attendant
est-ce qu'ils ont vendu leur hâme pour
avoir cette réussite
[Musique]
commerciale
à l'époque la l'ologie Suisse a essayé
de se sauver en produisant de d'année en
année des montre plus cher et moi comme
fabricant de composants ça signifie
aussi de d'année en année en plus petite
quantité alors pour moi c'est un cercle
vicieux comme fabricant de composants je
voyais déjà la fin de notre industrie de
base parce que le P de marché de la
montre chè pour un industriel est trop
petit pour survivre et nous avons
développé ce concept de montre bon
marché de haute qualité on a dû définir
les caractéristiques de cette MRE d'une
manière extrêmement dure parce que la
Suisse c'était pas le pays idéal pour
fabriquer des montre économique les
salaires sont les plus élevés du monde
et alors nous avons dû chercher une
solution extrêmement
agressive pour lutter contre toutes ces
ces éléments défavorables pour l'ologie
[Musique]
Suisse et on a immédiatement commencé
avec la conception marketing qu'on
voyait que techniquement ce produit
était faisable et c'est par chance qu'on
a rencontré personnellement Maxime grut
et moi-même le patron de Bloomingdale
Marvin troub qui nous a donné des leçons
de marketing comment il faudrait vendre
ce produit ce produit génial entre
guillemet aux États-Unis et il nous a
dit que nos nos nos couleurs qu'on avait
choisi étaient vilain vilaines et qu'on
qu'on qu'on pouvait jamais vendre ça il
nous a donné euh vraiment une leçon
comment il faudrait s'adapter à la mode
aux tendances de la mode et comment il
faudrait changer euh la la conception
esthétique de cette montre sans changer
la forme sans changer la technique de la
montre
[Musique]
personne n cru que ce produit pourrait
tellement
influencer le développement de de
l'industrieog Suisse je pense c'était
une surprise pour tout le monde et
c'était aussi un succès pour tout le
monde
OK
vers les années 90 oui on va en quelque
sorte un renouveau de la montre
mécanique mais il faut reconnaître que
ce
renouveau se liit surtout à la réussite
de certaines marques du moment qu'on
fait comprendre aux gens on fait croire
aux gens que la montre mécanique est un
objet spécial qui dépasse en
en en qualité disons
intérieure les gens commencent à à dire
bon comme
objet qui me permet de
paraître l'objet la la montre mécanique
a du prestige que la montre quartz n'a
[Musique]
pas
une vieille dame est venue dans notre
magasin à Genève elle nous a rapporté
une vieille monte de poche et cette
monte de poche elle l'avait récupéré du
Titanic je ne sais pas exactement
comment elle l'avait récupéré elle nous
avait demandé de la remettre en état ce
qu'on avait fait c'est une pièce qui
avait à peu près une centaine d'années
et je dire quand cette quand cette dame
est revenue prendre sa montre et sa
monre marchait sa montre faisait tac il
nous a dit ah mais j'ai l'impression que
mon mari qui était sur le bateau revit
en ce
[Musique]
moment il est bien possible que la
montre de l'avenir ne sera pas
indépendante
elle dépendra de
signaux diffusés précisément par des
centres horlogers ce sera un récepteur
récepteur de signaux et comme ça on aura
l'URE exacte mais on aura plus de
mouvement plus de mobile plus de quartz
et il y en a déjà des montres de ce
genre l'horloge atomique au sésium
enregistre un retard d'une seconde à
peine en 15 millions d'années la route a
été longue des premiers horlogés à nos
montres modernes tout droit sorti de
romans de
science-fiction
l'orloger et le propriétaire de montre
ont voulu tous deux la montre
idéale qu'elle soit bijou ou modèle de
précision chacun voulait sa montre
idéale mais cette montreel sûrement
n'existera
jamais la montre idéale serait la montre
qui
ne laisse s'écouler que des heures
[Musique]
heureuses